[Musique]
je m'appelle l'élégance et et j'ai 18
ans voici mes trois meilleurs amis
m bect et sarah
et je vais vous raconter comment ma
ville salem a perdu la tête
mais commençons par le début
et ils directeur s'est fait hacker
je lui donne à peu près cinq jours avant
de se suicider désolé j'ai pas trop de
sympathie pour les gens qui se font à
quai sérieux il ya deux genres de
personnes dans le monde tel qu'ils ont
acceptée qui avait privé soit un concept
dépassé et les vieux quai c'est encore
de résister
qu'est ce que tu as à cacher toute façon
un million de photos ni la porno
vraiment intense et des textos extra
pervers à propos de presque tout le
monde de l'école moi aussi j'en ai trois
vous savez je vis pour ce genre de
scandale y la moitié de salem s'est fait
pirater et personne ne peut rien faire
pour effacer ces vidéos on est page
personnelle de 17000 personnes sans
diffuser publiquement les gens
deviennent vraiment vita
collet
[Musique]
qui va regarder la photo d'une fille nue
et immédiatement se dire you faut que je
tue cette [ __ ] tu crois tu t'en vas
aller beaucoup plus de gens que vous
croyez
darty
c'est ton univers c'est toi qui a fait
ça
ces vertes plane sur moi je viens juste
d'arriver
tu peux me tuer moi mais tu peux pas
tous nous tuer